- What I think you're gonna see happen,
my sense is that as there are amendments,
modifications made to these restrictions,
they're gonna be geographic in nature.
They're gonna happen in
regions and/or states,
and they're not gonna happen all at once.
It's gonna be a slow progression
to a point that we can sustain,
'cause there is a balance here, right?
We're always gonna err on the side
of public health and public safety.
There is also only so much
you can ask of a society
before it begins to
push back or not comply.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and this
is "The Rubin Report."
Joining me today is the
senior senator from Florida,
Senator Marco Rubio, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Thanks for having me.
- Well, I'm glad you're doing this.
We've been trying to
get you for a long time.
We were hoping we were maybe
gonna do it live in Florida,
although the pandemic has at
least temporarily stopped us.
But let's just get right to it,
'cause I know you have limited time.
Well, how's life in
the middle of lockdown?
What are you going through?
What are you hearing
from people in Florida,
the whole thing?
- Yeah, it's a tough
time for a lotta people
on multiple levels.
Obviously, economically it's a time
of tremendous uncertainty.
It's disrupted people's daily routines,
people stuck at home for weeks on end,
and so that's been a challenge.
Then obviously, the
healthcare part at this point,
I can tell you we know
at least three people
who've had somebody in
their family either die
or very seriously ill at
this point from the virus,
so it's getting to become personal.
And then there's things you don't really
necessarily think about, but I told you
before we got on the air here,
I have a senior in high
school, my daughter.
That whole senior class
across the country,
their rites of passage, the
prom or a graduation ceremony,
all that's up in the air about
what's gonna happen next.
So it's just challenging
on multiple fronts.
But obviously, you also
think about these people
who are going out every day,
whether it's working at the grocery store
and exposing themselves to
hundreds of people daily
or working in those hospitals,
whether it's cleaning them or
all the way up to the doctors,
many of whom have been
infected themselves.
It's just a tremendous challenge that,
I know this word's been used a lot,
but there really is
nothing to compare it to.
- So I wanna spend most of our chat
talking about the things that
you're actually helping pass
to help people, but one quick
thing before we get to that,
what's your general philosophy
on what the states
should be doing right now
versus what the federal
government should be doing?
- I think federalism really helps us here.
It should be a state response,
and the reason why is because every state
is in a different situation.
And I think they are, number one,
most accountable to the people directly,
and second, in a country
this big, this diverse,
there's very rarely you're gonna have
a one-size-fits-all approach
that really functions well.
And so I think that's why
having the state response
is not just the right thing to
do on a constitutional basis
in my view, it's also common sense.
And what I think you're gonna see happen,
my sense is, that as there are amendments,
modifications made to these restrictions,
they're gonna be geographic in nature.
They're gonna happen in
regions and/or states,
and they're not gonna happen all at once.
It's gonna be a slow progression
to a point that we can sustain,
'cause there is a balance here, right?
We're always gonna err on the side
of public health and public safety.
There is also only so much
you can ask of a society
before it begins to
push back or not comply
with some of these requirements.
So it's not like we have unlimited time
to continue to leave these
things in place forever.
At some point, there will
have to be some modifications,
'cause people will simply stop complying
and make it hard to comply.
So it's a delicate balancing act thing,
and that's why I think it's important
that we have a state basis for it.
- Do you guys have a
particularly unique situation
in Florida because
weather-wise, it's warm,
and everyone's been saying
hopefully as the summer
rolls around, that'll help.
But on the other hand, I assume Florida
probably has one of the older populations,
oldest populations in the United States.
- Well, that's a good point.
So for example, we do have
rural areas that are sparse.
None of our urban areas
are as densely populated
as New York City, for example.
Same in California, these are
big cities, but people drive.
You can tell by how
many people are driving
or do people use public transportation?
That tells you a lot about density.
But the other thing that's unique,
and you've mentioned to it,
is we do have not just a
large senior population,
but a large concentrated
senior population,
everywhere from the villages
in North Central Florida
to multiple facilities
in Southeast Florida,
and very vibrant retiree
communities in Southwest Florida.
And so we have places
where a lot of people
in that high-risk category,
over 65 or whatever,
live together, and so outbreaks
in any of those places
could quickly strain the
local health services.
So that is one unique aspect.
And the other is we have a
lot of international travel
that comes through here
from all over the world
and from over the hemisphere,
so even if we emerge from this
at some point with good numbers,
we're only an outbreak in Latin America
and the Western hemisphere away
from seeing some of that
coming into our state,
whether it's visitors to Disney World
or people that come to do
business in South Florida.
- All right, so I really wanna focus in
on what the government is
actually hopefully doing right,
but maybe some of what it's
fumbling across the way.
I know you've been heavily involved
in the Paycheck Protection Program.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
- Yeah, the first thing I
wanna say about all of it
is understand the reason why
our government's even involved
is because the government
has told businesses
they can't function, you
can't open your doors,
you can't make any money, you can't work.
So it is a government order.
It's in essence a taking
in the public interest.
They've said, "I take your property,
"we have to compensate you
for it as a government.
"If I close your business,
"there's gotta be some level
of compensation for that."
So what's the right way to
do it is we've worked on.
We focused on the small business sector
in the committee that I chair,
and we came up with a formula
because we don't believe,
and I think I've been proven right,
that the existing emergency
loan program was gonna function.
But that program is designed for a tornado
or a flood or a hurricane
to hit or a wildfire
that hits a geographic area,
not a nationwide emergency.
So, there's been a lotta criticism
about the glitches the program's had,
and I just ask myself
what do people expect?
This bill passed on March
27th, so 17 days ago.
Seven days later, the
program was up and running,
but not perfectly.
We have a $350 billion
program half the businesses
in America are eligible
for, it's a massive program,
and it's never been done before.
So on that day, almost two Fridays ago,
it was the first time ever
that anyone on this planet
had ever done a PPP loan,
whether you were a banker,
the SBA, or even somebody applying for it.
So that was seven days
after the bill passed.
11 days after this program was started,
which is where we are today,
we already have billions of dollars
being disbursed into the
accounts of small businesses.
There are over a million small businesses
that have already been approved
and are in some process
of getting this funding,
representing millions of American jobs
that there's now a funding source
to keep them on payroll
for six to eight weeks.
I think that's a pretty
significant achievement
over a very short period of time.
Yes, there were glitches, of
course there were glitches.
That's the nature of crisis situations.
But I don't know of any precedent
where you have a program
of this size and magnitude
that ramps up and begins to reach people
at such a massive level in 17 days,
from the day it was signed into law.
- Yeah, I'm not making this up,
I have a small business here,
obviously my production
company that backs this show,
we found out about an hour ago
that we were actually cleared
for one of the small business loans,
so I know firsthand that this
is actually affecting people.
How do you decide whether money
should go to the small
businesses themselves,
or whether it should just
be put in people's pocket
for that sort of immediate burst
if they have to deal with
mortgage and buying groceries
and medical supplies, things like that?
- Well, the way we viewed it was,
at least from our
perspective, was two things.
It was good for most small businesses
to hold onto their employees
as long as they could,
because it would be disruptive for them
to have to lose all their employees
and then try to rehire everybody.
It would add time and
complexity to starting up again,
depending on what industry you're in.
They may never be able to start up again.
You can't just hire someone
off the street in 12 minutes,
train them on how to use
the dry cleaning machine
or even how to work the
systems for your restaurant.
We also think it's better for people
to be attached to an employer,
even if they're not going into work.
And the evidence of that is
there are plenty of people
out there that are still getting paid,
but either working from home,
or in some cases not even working at all,
but still getting paid.
I don't see them asking to be
laid off, for the most part.
And so the issue is we wanted
to keep that attachment.
In a time of so much uncertainty,
the last thing we want
is people sitting at home
not just out of a job, but not
even knowing if there's a job
for them to go back to at
any point in the near future.
So that was the rationale behind it.
Then the question is, well,
what is the best way to deliver it?
And the answer was not
through the SBA directly,
'cause this is a small agency,
but no federal agency
could have handled it.
We argued virtually every small business
has some banking relationship
or financial relationship of some kind.
Let's pay the bankers and
the lenders a processing fee
to basically do a no-risk
loan on their part,
because most of this is gonna be forgiven,
and whatever portion of it
becomes a loan, if it does,
is 100% guaranteed by
the federal government.
And that was the general
concept that we luckily
began working on weeks
before we were called upon,
because we kinda saw this coming,
and that was the idea behind it.
- Do you think this is all working
basically as well as it could be worked?
As you said, there's gonna be some flubs,
there's gonna be some
hiccups along the way,
but do you think that the system
basically is functioning
as it should right now?
- Yeah, there's two impediments
that people have to understand.
The first is there was some lateness
in issuing the guidance.
They opened up application that Friday,
the guidance didn't
come out until Thursday,
because the original guidance
that was put out by SBA
did not reflect legislative intent.
It was way too complicated.
And so, Treasury came in,
they spent all day that
Thursday fixing it.
It finally came out on Friday.
Then there were some followup questions,
simple things, but important,
like what note do we use?
What document do we use to close the loan?
Because we're not gonna close
unless you tell us what's approved
because a year from now, we don't want you
to come and tell us
that it's not guaranteed
because we used the wrong form.
So getting Treasury to
answer that question
is what really opened up the door.
And then the third is,
is there a market to sell some of these?
Because if you hold these on
your books, that's capital,
that's not federal cash that's going out,
it's cash out of the
balances of these lenders.
They wanna make sure that at some point,
at six, seven, eight weeks,
they can sell these things to somebody
So when the Fed came out Friday
and announced that they
would be able to take them
to the discount window
and get rid of these loans
off the books and have the feds own it,
that opened up the spigot as well.
So I wish we would have
done all of those things
three days earlier, but there's
a lot that goes into that,
but it happened.
Then the other issue is,
frankly, just capacity.
I mean, these are big banks,
but they didn't have 1,000 people
assigned to processing loans.
They had to repurpose a lot
of their internal systems
and employees to handle this kind of work
and train them up on how to do it.
So some of the backlog we've seen
has been inside the banks themselves,
who just weren't internally...
This is not what they do every day,
and so they had to repurpose
a lot of their existing folks
to be able to do some of this.
- So I wanna shift a little bit
and talk about China directly,
because one of the reasons I've wanted
to have you on the show for so long
is I've heard you give many
speeches on the Senate floor
about the uniqueness of America
and why you love this country so much,
and your family story,
and the whole thing.
We seem to be at this odd moment right now
where we're in this
relationship with China
that nobody can quite tell
if it's good, if it's bad,
if it's beneficial, did they spread it,
and now they're also
supposed to be our savior.
Can you clean up a little bit
about what's going on with China
and how we should be dealing
with them during this?
- Well, I doubt I could do it
in 10 minutes or 15 minutes.
It's a much broader conflict.
- (Dave laughing)
- But let me say this, China is a rich
and powerful and important country,
and will be for the rest of our lifetimes.
In fact, this entire
century will be defined
by the relationship between
the United States and China.
And they, for historic reasons and others,
they view it is their
rightful role in the world
from an historical perspective.
They view the last 100
years as an aberration
and it's their rightful role in the world
to be the most dominant and
powerful country on the planet.
And every nation's entitled to
whatever ambitions they want,
but from our perspective, we
have a relationship with them
and it has to be a balanced relationship,
because if the relationship
becomes unbalanced,
whether it's geopolitically
or economically,
we're gonna have a conflict.
We're already seeing conflict with them
when it comes to economics,
and we could eventually
see armed conflict as well,
which would be disastrous.
And so the only way to avoid that
is to have a balanced relationship.
I don't like the Chinese Communist Party.
I wish they were more democratic
and they adhered to human rights,
and I talk about those things.
But ultimately, that's
something that has to change
over there internally.
What we can control is
what our relationship
is like with them, and
we have made decisions
and public policy in
this country for 25 years
that have disadvantaged us,
because we thought that
when China got rich,
they would become like us.
But what we didn't realize
till recently I guess,
most people, is that what
they were actually undertaking
was a very meticulous, carefully crafted,
and patient effort to displace us,
and no longer to be the place
that makes cheap knockoffs,
but the actual place that is innovating,
and if they become great
innovators, that's fine,
but if their innovations are largely built
on intellectual property,
they'll have an unfair competition,
where their companies can
do whatever they want here,
but other companies from abroad
can't do whatever they want over there,
well, that's not a fair playing field.
And so we need to bring some
balance to that relationship,
and that's not what exists right now.
And so I think we have to
spend a lotta time working
on restoring a level of strategic balance,
both economically and geopolitically.
- So speaking of strategic balance,
the fact that we're getting
so many of our supplies from China,
the fact that our supply chain
has so much to do with China,
in a certain way, has
the ship sailed on that?
How do we actually fix some of this stuff,
especially because we're
going through this right now?
It's not like, all right,
maybe six months from now,
we can do the postmortem on it
and figure out here are
the mistakes we made.
But we actually do need things right now.
- Yeah, for the most part.
It's not like oil or it's in the ground
and they have it and we don't,
although that's not the
case with the United States,
but this is we've given it away,
because we made a decision,
and the market said that
the most efficient place
for these activities to
happen is somewhere else,
and China became that place.
And it became the most
efficient place initially
because of low labor costs,
but now it's also because
they subsidize and protect their companies
at the expense of everybody else.
And generally, that's fine.
That's the way capitalism should work.
That's why I support markets.
But what happens when the
most efficient outcome
is opposite of our national interest?
So for example, what happens
when the most efficient outcome
is that airplanes are only made in China,
and rare earth minerals can
only be procured from China,
and key medications can
only come from China?
Well, I'm not sure that's
in our national interest,
and some of that is
being exposed right now.
I'll tell you something
that we can do here
that it's very difficult
to offshore is agriculture.
So while you'll have some shortages
in some commodities and some disruptions,
but one thing you're not hearing about
is there may not be any toilet
paper at the grocery store,
but there's meat and there's chicken
and there's rice and there's vegetables.
That issue is not hurting us,
because we can feed ourselves,
and that's not an industry
you can just pick up
and move somewhere else.
We're very fortunate.
We need to be able to do some other things
that may not be the most
efficient place to do,
but we have to have some
capability of doing certain things.
I think one of the key pieces of work
that we have to put together
in the aftermath of all this
is defining what are those industries
that we're gonna have to have
some domestic capacity in
for purposes of national
economic and national security.
- So as we look at the stimulus package
and we look at refiguring
out our situation
with China and everything else,
what does getting America
back to work look like?
I know you're saying the states
should all sorta do their own thing,
but is this now the rest
of the year, do you think?
Is this well beyond that?
What does this actually kinda look like,
if you could paint a picture?
- That's the hardest question.
We just don't know, because
there's nothing to model this on
and I think a lot of it is
still unknown and uncertain.
Anyone who goes around
telling the dates is lying.
No one really knows yet.
But I think it really
begins a setting in our mind
a criteria for what is an
acceptable level of risk,
and remembering that we don't have
an unlimited amount of time here.
We're asking people to
comply with these orders,
but eventually people will begin
to push back on compliance.
They'll just stop complying,
and we're not gonna be arresting everyone
who decides they're gonna break a curfew
or because 10 people are
together at home somewhere.
So this is not forever.
We cannot do this even
if we wanted to forever,
and we don't want to,
and we can't from an economic perspective.
The second is what have
we done in the interim?
What are we doing right now?
If we can develop an antiviral
that keeps people off respirators,
keeps people out of ICU,
maybe even keeps them out of the hospital,
that's a major development.
And we're much closer to that
than we are to a vaccine,
which will eventually come.
And then I think part of it for all of us
is recognizing that it's not gonna be
like we're gonna go back to March 1st
and everything's gonna
open up and be the same.
I think it's gonna be a
gradual process of adjustment,
and I still expect that for
some significant period of time
many of us will still be
wearing masks in public places,
we'll still have to stand
six feet apart in the lines,
and we may not be able
to gather in large groups
at certain places, and
what that could mean,
and all kinds of things that
would be disrupted by it.
So, things may reopen,
some jobs may come back,
but it won't be the same for a while,
and that's gonna have economic
consequences to it as well.
So it reminds me a lot of the hurricanes
that we've become accustomed
to here in Florida.
You're sitting at home,
you know it's a bad storm,
you heard about it on the radio,
you can hear the wind howling,
see the trees bending,
maybe even breaking,
but you don't really know how bad it is
until the storm passes and you go outside
and take an assessment.
So we're still in the
middle of that storm,
and this storm's gonna
linger a little bit.
Even after we go outside,
it's still gonna be blowing.
There's gonna be a tail
to some of this economic
damage for a while.
- I wanna ask you something
that I talk to a lot of my
nonpolitical guests about,
but it might be interesting
to hear a politician's view on this.
Have you been able to have any time
to sorta just rethink what
you're doing with your life,
what do you wanna do in the future,
what you're doing with your family?
Just everyone trapped at home,
I do sense that the silver
lining to all of this
is that we are gonna start
thinking about the world
in a new way, what job we
have, whether we wanna commute,
where we're living, are we
too close to a big city,
et cetera, et cetera.
Have you guys had any
time to talk about that,
either with your wife, with your kids,
what they wanna do, all that sorta thing?
- Well, a little different I think,
and for me it's been more about
what a humbling experience
this is for everybody.
This is not a disease that wealth,
fame, power protects you from.
The prime minister of the
United Kingdom was gravely ill.
We've seen celebrities
and very wealthy people
be infected by it.
So this is something that reminds you
that there are things
we still don't control.
We are an advanced species,
we've done some extraordinary things
over the last 100 years scientifically,
and yet there are things
we cannot control.
There are things that
we are still limited.
I think as much as anything
else, this is a reminder
of how all of these things we've built,
you see these massive companies
and captains of industry
that were brought to
their knees very quickly
because the economy came to a
halt by a virus, by biology.
And it sorta reminds you
that in so many ways,
while we have great advances
and have achieved tremendous
things as a species,
we still have limits to the
things that we have control over
and that there are some things
that are not easy to solve.
We've also become a
society that's used to,
why haven't you invented the pill yet
that takes this away in five minutes?
Why haven't you come up with
a magic government program
that makes this all go away overnight?
And it's almost this assumption
that somehow there's this
logical, easy solution out there,
and we just haven't done it
because people don't wanna do it.
Every country in the
world's struggling with this
because there are certain
things in life still,
in the 21st century, that
require a lot of work
and a little bit of patience
and a little bit of humility
in confronting them because
they don't have easy answers,
they don't have easy solutions.
And for me, that certainly reminded us
that no matter how powerful
the U.S. government might be
and how much influence we
may have in it from our role,
there's only so much we can do,
but our job is to do our best.
- All right, so one more then,
which just sorta jumps off that
and sort of related to
some of the speeches
that I've heard you give.
Is there something that is unique
about the American experience,
about just American drive
and ingenuity and the
desire and action on freedom
that you think will help
us get through this,
where other countries
might struggle in a way
because it's not so much
in their national ethos,
where we have such a strong,
just independent streak within us?
- Yeah, two things that I would point to.
The first is our sense of community,
where you see people out
there right now at home
sewing masks and doing certain things
that could help out in their own way.
We've seen entire businesses
that have repurposed their production
for purposes of filling,
they heard about a
critical need in society
and they decided we were gonna meet it.
We've seen so many people
step up to the plate on that.
Even in this time with
so much polarization,
you've seen a lot of that happen,
and some of the most amazing stories
have nothing to do with famous
people or political people.
It has to do with everyday people
that are making extraordinary
steps to check on a neighbor
or provide food for an elderly person
who's sheltered at home
and can't go outside
because their life would be at risk.
And some of the stories you
hear in the emergency rooms
where these patients
are completely isolated
from loved ones, and doctors
are holding up the phone
before they intubate them
so they could speak to their relatives
potentially for the last time,
and the impact it's had
on them psychologically,
so just extraordinary stuff.
And then the second part about it
is our creativity and innovation.
You have a lot of creative,
innovative people out there right now
that are trying to solve
all sorts of problems.
The fact that you and I
are having this interview
despite the inability to be together.
I mean, 20 years ago I would need a studio
and you would need a studio,
and now we're doing it on
two laptops or two computers.
- For the record, as a small businessman,
I do have a home studio.
This is my garage, not bad, right?
(laughing)
- Okay, gotcha.
This is not my home studio,
but I had to put out fancy
lights just to be able to be lit.
But the thing is that
we have that creativity,
not just to solve the
problems we're facing now,
I mean, kids are learning.
It's not ideal or in the
classroom with their friends,
but we're instructing people.
All of these are innovations
that America brought about
and in many ways that made it possible.
But the other thing that's happening
is they're working on
solutions to this problem.
I believe we have the
brightest minds in the world
and the brightest minds in this country
thinking about how can we
come up with a vaccine?
How can we come up with an antiviral?
How can we make ventilators?
And you're already seeing
some of these companies
turn it around and take
small things and repurpose it
to be ventilators and medical
protective gear and so forth.
So, that extraordinary
power is still there
when our minds are
behind a united purpose.
And you see that, it's evident.
People aren't just sitting at home saying,
"When is the government
gonna come up with answers?"
The media might be asking that,
but everyday people are going out
and answering the question themselves
in their own communities.
That's a very unique American attribute
and one that I'm glad we still have.
- I love that answer, and senator,
I thank you for taking
the time, and stay safe,
and hopefully we'll be able
to do this in person sometime.
- Absolutely, stay safe, thank you.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist,
and if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.